if you see something as a forever option
then it probably means you do not
understand it well enough
to begin doing it
what's going on everyone i wanted to
make this short short video for you
um because i had a number of
conversations last week that resulted in
kind of this
consistent point of coaching which is
it's never going to work forever and so
i've seen this happen in so many
different situations where
people will try and give themselves a
reason to not even begin something
because they think
that there is an end to it when the
reality is
the only things that don't actually have
an end to them are things that you do
not understand
and so if you don't if you see something
as a forever option
then it probably means you do not
understand it well enough to begin doing
it
so there's a little mind for you um and
so let me give you a couple examples to
bring this home
so you know when i was you know in the
fitness space i had a lot of people
who'd
come up to me and be like hey man like i
want to start working out i want to get
bigger
i was like awesome you know this is how
you gotta train blah blah
and they'd be like well i don't want to
get too big i'm like
you don't even look like you work out so
why don't we start with that
and then we can worry about you getting
too big right so
it's not a perfect example for business
but that's an example of somebody
trying to discount starting because they
think they see an
end that they do not even understand the
journey well enough to comprehend
another example would be hey we're
running
tick-tock ads right now and we're
crushing it right and someone says
well we don't know how long tick tock is
going to be around
or snapchat or insert whatever new
opportunity there is
and so we don't want to do it right
but the reality is all opportunities
are by their very nature arbitrage where
you're taking advantage of
inefficiencies within two systems or two
markets
and so over time all arbitrage
disappears right and then markets become
more efficient that's how markets work
right more and more people see the
opportunity the bit the arbitrage
decreases until eventually it's
efficient
right and so when you're looking at
opportunities
and you see something and it might be a
big opportunity only is going to be open
for two years three years do you do it
or not it's another series of questions
that would happen after that
but i would not discount it simply
because you know that it is finite
because all opportunities are finite
and to take this exaggera you know this
example to a max degree of exaggeration
think about the fortune 500 there's only
one company that's been on there
for over 100 years and that's ge just
one one company
right and so every one of those
companies you might have thought or
during their day might be like this
thing's going to be here forever
the reality is it's not and markets
change so rapidly it's difficult to
reshift an entire infrastructure
some companies can do it many fail and
so if your business
is founded upon taking advantage of an
arbitrage opportunity
or an inefficiency in a marketplace or
something that is fleeting
right that comes and goes that's okay
many businesses were built off of
arbitrage
opportunities that created cash flow
human resources
that could then be deployed and pivoted
in another direction
when the opportunity closes and so it's
kind of like saying
well i don't want to invest in this
investment
because it's only going to triple my
money in three years well what do i do
after it triples my money
well you take the money you invest it
somewhere else right
it's the same concept except you're just
applying it to your business
and so this is just a caveat that was
top of mind that i figured i would share
with you
because just so many times we try and
take 10 steps forward without even
realizing that there's this
big pile of money and you can just pick
it up and move about your life and it
doesn't need to be forever
and so it's just a remembering like if
this were an investment would you triple
your money in three years
probably so then don't worry about what
you're going to do in 20 years because
you're going to be such a different
person than anyways you might not even
want to be in the same thing forever
and so i think sometimes we just create
this reason
because the real reason is that we fear
failing when something seems so
easy right we fear failing because we
might not think we're good enough
or we're being lazy and we don't want to
even start or try
and so it's usually the fear thing but
for some people
you shouldn't get off your ass um but
anyways i hope i i hope you found this
valuable
uh maybe this you're at a decision right
now or you're thinking about investing
something or
you're thinking about taking advantage
of an opportunity or think about
investing your time
into taking advantage of some sort of
inefficiency
and if it's a massive one even if it's
going to be fleeting as long as the
return is high enough
i think many times it can be worth it so
anyways this is more targeted for newer
entrepreneurs if you're in an existing
vehicle it means you've already
found an arbor shop opportunity so don't
try and do another one
um unless it's something that feeds your
original model
but anyways i hope that makes sense keep
being awesome have a fantastic day and
i'll catch you next video
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you